[Musique]
bonjour à regarder niché à ces pays au
tampon australe en septembre quand j'ai
su que
je suis monsieur s'appelle danger fille
57 ans gérant de la société à ces pays
avec sac associés
suis dans mon parcours dans le bâtiment
en tant qu'adjoint travaux avec mes
associés on a relevé une problématique
cette problématique était lié à l'eau
chaude donc ensemble a décidé de trouver
une solution à cette problématique
pour mener à bien cette entreprise on a
été accompagné par l'adie et pôle emploi
ce qui nous a permis aujourd'hui d'être
en phase de pré commercialisation
[Musique]
on voit pas à projets innovants un
ballon d'eau chaude connectés
communicants qui permet à ses
utilisateurs de gérer cette fois dans sa
propre température par le biais d'un
smartphones ou téléphones mobiles
eux ce ballon et économique écologique
de par son mode de gestion qui permet à
son utilisateur de réduire sa facture
d'électricité et de maîtriser sa
consommation d'énergie
[Musique]
et nous allons proposer un logiciel
informatique permettant la gestion d'un
parc de ballons d'eau chaude à partir
d'un poste totalisé 1 bailleurs sociaux
par exemple il aura la possibilité de
gérer tout son équipement en jouant sur
la température et ainsi de faire des
économies d'énergie
[Musique]
on in start-up parce que notre ballon
intelligent n'existe nulle part dans le
monde on a obtenu la médaille de bronze
au concours lépine de par son mode de
gestion de mode de gestion avec pull
perspectives de commercialisation qui
peut s'étendre au niveau national et
international
selon lé ballon répond aux nouvelles
contraintes environnementales
[Musique]
comme le paille-en-queue on vole haut et
on voit loin